les lois de la nature sont inévitables
rien ni personne en ce monde ne peut
leur échapper
ensuite il ya le genre de nana que je
qualifie de trous noirs supermassifs
elle est peut-être super canon mais
aussi super louche et pour ne rien
arranger elle se prend pour le centre de
la galaxie
en théorie elle peut même se transformer
en trou de ver elle est capable de
t'arracher du monde que tu connais et de
te transporter dans un univers parallèle
dans l'histoire le trou s'est elle
tandis que le verset c'est moi je suis
vert enfin en train de tomber amoureux
je suis tombé amoureux le jour où je lui
suis rentré dorin toi c'est comment avec
la
et elle non plus je crois ou tu me
donnes la main ou je te fais une scène
que t'es pas prêt d'oublier mon coeur
non la terre dynamique toutes les pré
déterminé à partir d'un petit nombre de
lois et les boucles serrées pour garder
pour nous ça laisse aucune place à la
volonté n'est qu'une illusion
ou peut-être une illusion mais les gens
n'arrêtent pas de baiser
ces petits mannequins des métis où
qu'elle aille au delà d irak
ça va mal se finir on n'a rien en commun
à toi et moi tu vas souffrir même quand
on aura l'impression que tout se passe
bien je crois qu'on ferait mieux de
faire une petite pause
heureusement je m'en suis rendu compte
dès le début et j'ai pas baisser la
garde
mais là
mais ça je porte les choses les lois de
la physique ne peuvent pas s'appliquer à
l'amour une fois que la thermodynamique
est entré dans votre vie elle ne vous
abandonne jamais
bienvenue dans le monde des lois de la
thermodynamique
vous en pensez quoi je suis sain ville